[Musica]
buon pomeriggio sono arianna peduzzi
sono un ingegnere di l'architetto è
attualmente una dottoranda del corso di
ingegneria dell'architettura qui alla
sapienza oggi sono qui per raccontarvi
che cosa mi ha spinto a entrare in
questo settore e soprattutto per
parlarvi un pochino di quello di cui mi
occupo
subito dopo la laurea devo ammettere che
ero piuttosto confusa come tanti infatti
ho iniziato a cercare lavoro e questo mi
ha fatto entrare in una profonda crisi
non volevo infatti diventare un
ingranaggio all'interno di un settore
come quello edile che è simbolo delle
grandi disuguaglianze che caratterizzano
il nostro tempo e che soprattutto è uno
dei grandi responsabili del cambiamento
climatico attualmente in atto proprio
per questo invece di seguire quello che
consideravo essere il percorso
tradizionale e invece quindi di andare a
cercare lavoro presso uno studio di
ingegneria
ho deciso di seguire una strada
alternativa decidendo quindi di
continuare a studiare e iscrivendomi al
dottorato
volevo infatti ritagliarmi uno spazio
all'interno di un settore che vedevo
profondamente ingiusto e che fosse
invece è allineato con quello che
credevo dovesse essere il mondo di
domani
un mondo più equo e soprattutto più
sostenibile
proprio per questo mi sono cominciato a
chiedere come fare i dati che ho
incontrato all'inizio del mio percorso
erano tutt'altro che incoraggianti
infatti purtroppo il settore delle
costruzioni e responsabile del 38 per
cento dell'anidride carbonica emessa
ogni anno in atmosfera è anche
responsabile di una produzione di
rifiuti anna che solo in unione europea
equivale al 36 per cento stiamo quindi
parlando di un quantitativo di rifiuti
equivalente a 374 milioni di tonnellate
annue infine è responsabile anche di un
consumo di materie prime e di risorse
che oscilla tra il 30
il 50 per cento
a partire da questo quadro il mio primo
pensiero è stato
basta è finita siamo spacciati
tuttavia questa allarmante contesto ci
offre la possibilità di una rilettura
rovesciando infatti il punto di vista il
grande impatto che caratterizza il
comparto dell'edilizia ne implica anche
una grande potenzialità trasformativa
andare ad agire su di esso e soprattutto
sui suoi metodi produttivi può
consentire di trasformarlo in un settore
chiave per il processo di
decarbonizzazione e soprattutto per la
lotta al cambiamento climatico
non è infatti un caso che negli ultimi
40 anni l'architettura e l'edilizia
siano state sconvolte da dei cambiamenti
che mi azzarderei a definire piuttosto
epocali e che soprattutto negli ultimi
vent'anni le politiche globali ci siano
allineate e si sono allineate proprio
nell'andare a promuovere un nuovo tipo
di edilizia un tipo di edilizia che
permetta di costruire edifici a basso
consumo oa consumo nullo e financo a
impatto positivo e questo che cosa
significa significa essere in grado di
progettare e soprattutto costruire
edifici in grado di produrre energia
tuttavia questo non basta in realtà a
dare ad agire sulla nuova costruzione a
una risonanza piuttosto limitata
specialmente in un contesto come quello
europeo questo contesto è infatti
contrassegnato da un parco immobiliare
che vi azzarderei a definire piuttosto
vecchiotto passatemi il termine si stima
infatti che circa l'ottanta per cento
degli edifici che verrà utilizzato e che
verrà occupato nel 2050 esista già è
questo che cosa implica questo implica
un ingente consumo di risorse e di
energia volte al mantenimento del
comfort all'interno di questi edifici e
per ottenere ciò è i mezzi principali
sono sicuramente
quelli legati al riscaldamento e al
raffrescamento che come tutti voi ben
sapete sono operazioni decisamente
energivore
da questo quadro appare quindi come
l'edificato esistente giochi un ruolo
centrale nel raggiungimento della
sostenibilità da parte dell'intero
settore e questo ruolo è reso ancor più
importante se ci focalizziamo su
l'obiettivo fissato dalla commissione
europea per il 2050
un obiettivo che prevede una riduzione
del 90 per cento delle emissioni
associate al settore delle costruzioni
un obiettivo piuttosto ambizioso
considerato lo stato di fatto
sulla volontà e sulla scia di questa
volontà o meglio
numerosi documenti politici come ad
esempio il green deal ma anche il reno
version wave si sono espressi indicando
nelle strategie di ristrutturazione e
soprattutto di retrofit energetico
le due strategie più importanti per
andare a ridurre l'impatto ambientale
del settore nel prossimo futuro
e soprattutto il retrofit energetico è
stato indicato come la strategia
principe si calcola infatti che andare a
praticare questa tipologia di operazione
solo edificato esistente in maniera
capillare
consentirebbe una riduzione dell'energia
primaria associata agli edifici
equivalente al 17 per cento che una
quota enorme
tuttavia un quesito sorge spontaneo come
andare a praticare in queste operazioni
di retrofit infatti questa tipologia di
intervento che purtroppo comporta la
produzione il trasporto e anche
l'applicazione di nuovo materiale
costruttivo e questo ovviamente si
traduce in nuovo consumo di risorse
nuova generazione di rifiuti e nuove
emissioni dannose per l'ambiente
appare quindi evidente come una scelta
oculata dei materiali costruttivi
risulti centrale per il mantenimento
della sostenibilità di tali operazioni
i materiali infatti sono da una parte il
fattore che maggiormente può influire
sul successo di questi interventi
avendo infatti il potere di andare ad
agire su alcuni i parametri che
maggiormente possono comportare il
comfort all'interno degli edifici come
ad esempio le caratteristiche termiche e
idrometriche degli involucri edilizi
dall'altra però se però purtroppo i
materiali sono anche il fattore che
potrebbe andare a minare l'efficienza
del efficientamento energetico e stesso
in quanto sono spesso associati e
vengono spesso assieme a una quota di
energia incorporata piuttosto elevati
sarebbe quindi
una buona strategia andare a scegliere
ove possibile materiali a basso impatto
ambientale e addirittura di riciclo da
questo quadro appare quindi evidente
come gli sforzi dell'intero settore si
dovrebbero orientare all'andare a
ripensare ai processi produttivi alla
base della generazione dei materiali
costruttivi tradizionali specialmente in
riferimento a quelli maggiormente
utilizzati proprio per questo ho deciso
di lavorare con due di questi materiali
ovvero ho deciso di lavorare con le
paste cementizie e gli intonaci di gesso
con l'obiettivo di ridurne l'impatto
così da renderli dei candidati fattibili
per le operazioni di retrofit energetico
per fare questo ho pensato di utilizzare
una risorsa che purtroppo o per fortuna
possediamo in grandi quantità sul suolo
europeo ovvero ho deciso di utilizzare i
rifiuti pensandoli come una nuova
materia prima seconda che potesse
concorrere alla realizzazione e alla
produzione di nuovo materiale
costruttivo per fare questo sono andata
a identificare i maggiori flussi di
rifiuti europei che si sono
svelati essere quelli associati al
settore dell'agricoltura e quelli
associati sorprendentemente al settore
edile da questo sono poi andato a
selezionare due tipologie di rifiuti che
fossero facilmente trovabili sul suolo
italiano e quindi ho selezionato questi
rifiuti con cui ho continuato a lavorare
e chi erano fondamentalmente il canapo
lo di canapa e lo scarto ceramico l'idea
alla base dello studio che ho poi
sviluppato nei tre anni di dottorato era
quella di andare a realizzare degli
elementi di involucro che fossero in
grado di agire attivamente sulla qualità
e sulla salubrità dell'ambiente
costruito per fare questo sono andata a
fissare un obiettivo principale dello
studio che mi ha un po sostenuto durante
tutto il mio percorso e questo obiettivo
consentiva consisteva perdonatemi nel
verificare la realizzabilità di elementi
di involucro opaco sostenibili che
avessero un impronta di carbonio ridotta
e che soprattutto fossero in grado di
agire sul comfort all'interno e
all'esterno degli edifici sui quali
risultassero applicati per fare questo
ho quindi ideato prodotto e studiato due
materiali per finitura uno per
applicazione esterna a base di malta
cementizia e l'altro per applicazioni
interna a base di intonaco di gesso a
questi due composti sono poi andata ad
aggiungere i materiali che vi ho citato
precedentemente e nello specifico sono
andato ad aggiungere il canapo lo di
canapa all'interno della malta e lo
scarto ceramico all'interno
dell'intonaco lo scopo di queste
addizioni era duplice da una parte
infatti voleva andare a cercare di
migliorare uno e possibili alcune delle
caratteristiche che andavano a con
naturare questi due composti e nello
specifico volevo cercare di migliorare
le proprietà meccaniche di entrambi e le
proprietà
termo igrometriche dell'intonaco
dall'altra parte
dall'area applicare questi rifiuti aveva
lo scopo di ridurre l'energia
incorporata all'interno di queste due
paste e minimizzando al contempo il
flusso di rifiuti conferiti a discarica
ogni anno adesso non preoccupatevi non
sarò qui a elencare vi la lista di tutte
le prove co condotto né tantomeno i
risultati e grafici ad essi associati
per vostra fortuna mi hanno concesso
solo pochi minuti
tuttavia quello che vi posso dire è che
entrambi composti hanno risposto
piuttosto positivamente
infatti i risultati mi hanno dimostrato
come fosse effettivamente possibile
andare a realizzare degli elementi
costruttivi per la finitura interna ed
esterna sostenibile a partire dagli
scarti che aveva utilizzato e nello
specifico molto brevemente sono stata in
grado di realizzare una volta che
contenesse un 20 per cento di cannes
apolo di canapa in sostituzione
dell'inerzia tradizionale e che era
caratterizzata da una densità ridotta
che consentiva quindi la realizzazione
di elementi alleggeriti era
caratterizzata da una buona durezza
superficiale e da una buona resistenza
meccanica da una migliore conducibilità
termica e da una buona resistenza fronte
al fuoco nonché da una ridotta altezza
di risalita capillare
dall'altra parte invece sono stata in
grado di realizzare un intonaco che
contenesse un 40 per cento in peso dello
scarto ceramico che è un quantitativo
piuttosto alto e questo composto era
caratterizzato da una migliore
resistenza e durezza superficiale da una
migliore resistenza meccanica non chieda
un inferiore coefficiente di
assorbimento di vapore acqueo e da una
ridotta altezza di risalita capillare
adesso che sono arrivata quasi alla fine
nel mio percorso mi sento di poter
tirare un po le somme di questa
esperienza la cosa che mi ha reso più
felice di tutti questi tre anni non è
tanto legata ai risultati positivi che
ho ottenuto anche se ammetto che veder
validate le proprie ipotesi è stato
piuttosto appagante
ma quello che mi ha reso veramente
felice è stato il poter dimostrare che
immaginare e soprattutto realizzare
un'architettura e un'edilizia diverse
forse effettivamente possibile
chiaramente il percorso è ancora lungo
ed è costellato da ostacoli ostacoli
legati alle processi normativi ostacoli
produttivi ostacoli anche legati alla
diffidenza di alcuni operatori del
settore ma sapendo che anche il lavoro
di ricerca umile condotto da quella che
alla fine è una principiante sapendo che
questo lavoro di ricerca sia stato in
grado di dimostrare che effettivamente
immaginare nuovi processi produttivi sia
possibile beh queste sfide non mi fanno
più paura ma anzi mi riempiono il cuore
di determinazione e di speranza
essere qui con voi oggi mi dà inoltre la
possibilità di condividere una
consapevolezza a cui sono addivenuti
durante questi tre anni e questa
consapevolezza consiste nel fatto che
anche gli avanzamenti in un settore che
può sembrare meno dinamico e poco
centrale rispetto allo sviluppo
tecnologico
nel quale tutti stiamo correndo anche
questi avanzamenti hanno importato che
trascende il loro vero campo di
applicazione e sono anzi centrali per la
lotta al cambiamento climatico e
soprattutto per la costruzione di un
mondo più equo e più sostenibile grazie
grazie